what's up people Ryan right over here
today I'm gonna be watching the final
trailer the extended TV spot for
Marvel's Avengers age of Ultron called
let's finish this I've been told by subs
and this is the final one I just
uploaded about two hours ago my one's
for TV spot three and four I feel like a
lot of the time when trailers keep
coming out it keeps giving away way too
much surprisingly I don't feel like a
lot has been ruined for me and at the
same time each trailer gets me more and
more pumped
boss actually he's the boss I just pay
for everything design everything make it
look cooler
love that gamer man The Avengers happy
to possibly shopping
show them what we got nice
that's all mostly Ellie yeah
it's time for some fun
she's there's everyone make first a few
tickets now what been dango [ __ ] love
it man it just doesn't get any better
than that
the humor is still very much present
it's fun seeing all these guys come
together I got a couple of new thoughts
from the trailer actually I was thinking
about Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch in
their origin they are the children of
magneto and I know Magneto's on my Fox I
heard some rumor that they might be part
of Marvel phase for now but I know
Quicksilver was in Days of Future past
and this is a completely different
Quicksilver it seems actually more true
to its origins I'm wondering are they
gonna hint at magneto being their father
because if they do that then that means
we get x-men in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe which would be [ __ ] sweet
Quicksilver already looks like he has
more of an angst kind of a lot more
anger he looks like a darker version
than the one in Days of Future past that
scene on the bike with Scarlett
Johansson who is a lovely lady by the
way very beautiful to look at and she's
a very talented actress
there's a reason I'm saying that that
scene on the bike kind of reminding me
of Trinity and the Matrix Reloaded
actually looks a lot like it you know
she's in leather and she's on a
motorcycle zipping through lanes and
stuff that was a really sweet moment
when she went out of the truck did that
fast and furious maneuver and then
through cap the shield that climactic
shot that we keep seeing in the trailers
where all the Avengers are in a circle
they're just [ __ ] every one of all
those robots --is ah it's gonna be so
[ __ ] cool I'm going to like I'm 9:30
a.m. showing I'm gonna be the most
excited at 9:30 no one's excited at 9:30
in the morning but I'm gonna be thank
you guys for telling me this trailer is
out if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects and you
can follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter uh social network plugs got to
get more followers as a youtuber it is
required
Marina Bruno hi there I just wanted to
say that I checked out your vids and I
love your channel I'm a filmmaker on
nine
and it's a woman baby female subscriber
was so we need more of you whoa you look
like you're Filipino or something which
is good I'm half Filipino no you're
definitely not Filipino you look like
some type of ethnic personality I'm a
filmmaker I'm 19 and I made seven short
films and I'm finishing up my first
feature that's a major [ __ ]
accomplishment since you guys review
critique indie films I wanted to ask you
if you could check out my work sure
for one of the ten female subscribers
absolutely I think you'll enjoy my stuff
I'm looking for an audience to share my
work with so I hope you can check out
some of my films I promise you won't be
wasting your time thank you so much
Marina Bruno where do I get the
information to check out your
independent short films scratch that
let's promote you marina Bruno is one of
the most talented filmmakers I have ever
seen her films capture human emotion
better than any other filmmaker I've
ever seen and just remember marina as a
female in the film business it's gonna
be hard it's gonna be really difficult
you might want to try to make it before
you're 30 cuz after that I just pissed
off my girl
you